I don't think he should have been out of
jail why do you think he should be loud
because what he did was horrible and I
don't know I just I don't like him why
don't you like him what did he do
uh
uh you don't know what he did I do but
like I don't really know specifically
how can you say you don't like someone
if you don't know what they did my
friend said what did your friends say
I forget it was first semester wait
don't you think like before you should
before someone says oh that person
should be in jail you should like know
what they've done no yes okay so I'll
ask you the question again should Andrew
take me in or out of jail
he should be in jail even though they
can't find evidence
oh man that sounds pretty unethical to
anything